drama outer Bank star Madeline Klein
opens up about working with her co-star
and exchange Stokes after their split as
she Graces the cover of Cosmopolitan
magazine we definitely have boundaries I
mean for sure the actress reveals that
she and Chase made a pact to keep it
professional quote we always said that
the job remains untouched nothing else
personal or negative will touch the job
John B we are fugitives
although Madeline admits that it hasn't
been easy saying the two are clear that
their job is to leave the show better
than they found it adding I'm really
appreciative of that I think it's cool
to give people some sort of Hope and I
think this show does a really good job
Maddie and I have talked about this a
lot
um of an honest authentic take on what
it should be like to be in a young
relationship yeah um we definitely
wanted to highlight that like the you
know what a what a healthy
two-way relationship looks like
um especially for you know for a younger
audience they did it for a year before
splitting in November of 2021 just
before production kicked off for season
three of Outer Banks Madeleine tells the
mag that although she doesn't owe anyone
an explanation one thing she regrets
about their relationship is making it so
public quote I am a really private
person there's a part of me that is for
me and nobody else but in hindsight
making my relationship public made it
everybody else's business she adds it
just hit me like a freight train I
wanted us both to move on and be happy
people see the need for science there
are no sides there's no winning or
losing in a breakup sometimes that's
incredibly real though like sometimes
you know you just can't help it well
when it comes to love it sounds like
Maddie is winning right now love is
tight she reveals to Cosmo that she is
happily taken at the moment and while
she stands by her lesson learned of
keeping things private it's perfectly
vague she does admit she's incredibly
happy saying I've truly never been and
happier and I feel very very empowered
[Music]